im nahen osten nichts neues
nationalismus religiöser fanatismus
ungelöste konflikte schließlich der
berühmte funke der geradewegs ins
pulverfass fliegt und dann fliegen
raketen richtung israel beziehungsweise
in den gazastreifen soll das immer so
weitergehen aus aktuellem anlass
eskalationen nahost droht ein neuer
krieg jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet sind holt tages
dass sie ist die leiterin der
palästinensischen mission hier in
deutschland aus jerusalem
moshe zimmermann historiker und
emeritierter professor an der
hebräischen universität jerusalem hier
im studio ist antonia jamin
chefkorrespondent in europa israelischen
senders kann also public broadcasting
corporation ein öffentlicher
fernsehsender von schließlich michael
lüders nahost-experte und präsident der
deutsch arabischen gesellschaft herr
zimmermann
woher kommt eigentlich die offenbar
nicht nachlassende leidenschaft in
israel und palästina sich seit
jahrzehnten das leben mit gewalt
konflikten schwer zu machen
die ursachen sind ja klar aber
offensichtlich ist da kein richtiger
friedens wille da ich weiß jetzt mal
früher so formuliert die angst vor dem
frieden ist größer hier als die angst
vor dem krieg heute den tieren bewohnt
und deswegen kann es immer so
weitergehen
man kann jetzt auch mehr oder weniger
plan in kurzen abschnitten er haben wir
lebenszeiten oder ruhezeiten dann wieder
etwas auseinandersetzung dazu noch ein
bisschen krieg und dann wieder eine art
von von der ruhe damit fahren können die
leute hier am besten geben das klingt
für europäer sehr seltsam aber nur so
kann man erklären weshalb die zwei
völker die hier nebeneinander geben
diese art von gemeinsamen selbstmord
weiter verfügen jetzt ist ja alles wie
gehabt
es gibt gegenseitige schuldzuweisungen
zwischen israelisch israelis und
palästinensern jetzt auch in dem
aktuellen konflikte die frage immer wer
ist schuld an der eskalation immer die
anderen fangen wir mal bei ihnen an
gibt es zu wenige friedens willige unter
den palästinensern
gut also weil ich nicht sicher bin dass
die ursache des konfliktes klar sind auf
wie wir das in den letzten tagen in der
berichterstattung der mit geklickt haben
und ich mir wünsche dass wir eine
vernünftige debatte führen die die
ursachen beleuchten
erlauben sie wird erst mal fragen so zu
stellen die vielleicht auch unseren
emotionalen zustand reflektieren und
zwar war diese eskalation nicht
vorauszusehen könnte man das nicht
verhindern
warum gewinnen jetzt die ereignisse erst
in den letzten zwei tagen
diese aufmerksamkeit in den medien und
werden heftig diskutiert warum finden
die internationalen politiker erst jetzt
klare worte sich zu äußern auch
einseitig sagen ist das leben der
palästinenser weniger wert als die der
israelis für mich zählt jedes
menschenleben und meinen wir sind nicht
wie wo und dann kriegen wir sind ein
risiko gerne brechen darf ich hab ja es
geht ja sie wollen ja es geht ja um die
frage offensichtlich endlich nehme ihre
antwort dass eigentlich die
palästinenser und ich vermute mal auch
die allermeisten israelis frieden wollen
die frage gibt es ich werde die gleiche
frage gleich frau emine auch stellen und
zwar ob es zu wenig friedens willige und
israelis gibt meine frage war gibt es zu
wenig friedens willige unter den
palästinensern dass diese konflikte wir
reden über die ursachen und wir reden
auch über den aktuellen konflikt gleich
noch weiter die diese konflikte immer
wieder aufbrechen lassen gibt es auch
unter den palästinensern zu wenig
friedens willige sie sie wissen ich
vertrete ja die politische führung die
sich nur für eine politische lösung
einsetzt für die sogenannte
zwei-staaten-lösung die ja eigentlich
perspektive losgeworden ist vielleicht
das ist ja auch die ursache die zu
dieser situation geführt hat nein es
gibt genug willige palast in der
friedens willige palästinenser
nur diese politische perspektive
losigkeit das nicht genutzt hat das
kernproblem ist diese anspruchnahme auf
das land auf ganz palästina dass die
rechtsnormen hier nicht geld denn das
menschenrechte nicht universell sind
also das heißt der big and shoots die
gelten nur für für israel nicht für
palästina hier werden hierfür gleich
gesetz besatzungsmacht setzten volk und
gleiche standards adoptiert also diese
vielen jahre der politischen
verhandlungen wo wir auch völkerrechts
auf etlichen un resolutionen setzen wo
wir diplomatische politische arbeit
fortsetzen auch vor internationalen
gremien wurde nicht schon eher ignoriert
parallel dazu systematischer
strukturelle staatsgewalt besatzung
gewalt die die menschen systematisch
unterdrücken diskriminieren
diskriminieren bis zum apartheid was
erwarten sie gibt es ein folgt auf
dieser erde die sich mit besatzung des
gremiums sei wieder die ganz kurze sache
unterbrechen wir werden diese ganzen
themen gleich noch ansprechen
es geht ja auch um ursachen muss man
sagen dass wir zumindest das nach der
staatsgründung in israel 148 zunächst
mal vor allen dingen ja auch die
aggression von arabischer seite ausging
und dann ja auch diese ganzen kriege
entstanden sind jetzt übrigens ja auch
zur israelischen besatzung von
arabischen gebiet geführt haben frau
emine auch an sie die frage gibt es nach
diesem konflikt der jetzt wieder
aufgetaucht ist und wir haben immer
wieder die gleichen abläufe in den
letzten jahren jahrzehnten entweder
kriege oder solche bürgerkriegsähnlichen
zustände kämpfe militärische gewalt gibt
es auch unter den israelis zu wenig
friedens billige dass die immer weiter
mit diesem zustand offensichtlich
zufrieden sind das immer wieder von
neuem auch solche phoenix runde gemacht
werden müssen
droht da jetzt krieg' wir haben die
schon x-mal gemacht und offenbar hat
sich da nichts bewegt also ich denke
dass im endeffekt es genug israelis gibt
wo schon frieden möchten wir sehen das
ja auch in der politik politische lage
in
israel wer hat denn jetzt vier mal
wahlen
man versucht auch den premierminister
netanyahu abzuwählen also es gibt genug
leute wo auch eine andere richtung gehen
möchten
aber die frage ist auch vielleicht wenn
viele israelis immer noch an den frieden
glauben also das wäre auch eine frage
weil frieden wollen das denke ich schon
genug leute auch auf die israelische
seite und auch auf der palästinensischen
seite
die frage ist eher wenn die beide volker
noch an diesen frieden überhaupt glauben
und wenn sie glauben dass es machbar ist
ist die frage führen die politischen und
militärischen führungen den konflikt
oder für die völker diesen konflikt bis
hin zum krieg
also wenn sie mich fragen sage ich das
sind die politiker wenn du das so lange
es zwei terror organisationen gibt die
hamas und die hisbollah die israel von
norden und von süden in die zange nehmen
kann es keinen frieden geben denn diese
organisationen sind ja an dem an einem
frieden gleich welcher art überhaupt
nicht interessiert im gegenteil sie
haben ja die vernichtung israels sich
auf die fahnen geschrieben ist das ein
ganz großes lösungs problem von
arabischer seite das vielleicht auch von
den gemäßigten arabischen staaten nicht
stark genug auf hamas und hisbollah
nochmal sind terrororganisationen
eingewirkt wird zunächst einmal denke
ich sollte man nicht zu viele dinge in
einen topf werfen also zwischen hamas
und hisbollah muss man schon auch mal
unterscheiden des dollar ist eine
bedrohung ist libanesische miliz und das
andere ist eine palästinensische
organisation die sich als widerstand
organisation versteht
der kern des konfliktes ist vereinfacht
gesagt erfolgen werden wir zwei
konfliktparteien die eine konfliktpartei
die israelische verfügt über quasi alle
machtmittel und die andere die
palästinensische seite verfügt über
keine machtmittel ist es eine situation
von macht und ohnmacht und wir erleben
in den letzten jahren das unter der
regierung von netanjahu
die israelischen regierungen versucht
haben immer mehr palästinensisches land
vor allem im westjordanland
völkerrechtswidrig zu annektieren
das muss man sich vor augen führen wir
tun immer so als sei das
irgendwie ein metaphysischer konflikt da
gibt es irgendwie menschen die verstehen
sich nicht sagen wie tragisch das ist
ein konflikt da geht es um die
verteilung von ressourcen und von macht
und die überwiegend der
rechtskonservativen regierung die wir
gehabt haben in israel in den letzten
jahren haben eine ganz klare agenda und
die besteht darin so viel wie möglich
von palästina einzuverleiben in den
jüdischen staat zu kooperieren was
eindeutig völkerrechtswidrig ist aber
der bloße unter der bloße umstand dass
jede einzelne siedlung den von israel
gebaut worden ist im westjordanland
beispielsweise und das der annexion von
ostjerusalem das ist alles
völkerrechtswidrig ist findet in unserem
bewusstsein der überhaupt nicht statt
wir haben jetzt um das noch zu erwähnen
eine eskalation der situation dadurch
dass während des ramadans die
palästinenser großen sanierungen
ausgesetzt waren und man die al aksa
moschee zu kommen was die emotion
natürlich angeheizt hat aber vor allem
ist der zündfunken gewesen die
israelische inbesitznahme von häusern im
stadtteil schilksee
israel betrachtet ganz jerusalem als
hauptstadt israels
das sieht man hier in deutschland
mittlerweile auch so das ist aber
völkerrechts finde ich mein business
club und klar sagen und das ist noch
wichtig zu erwähnen was die israelische
seite versucht ist in sheikh jarrah und
anderswo so viel palästinensisches land
an sich zu reißen wie es nur geht um auf
diese weise einen keil zu treiben in den
ostteil von jerusalem die ganze
hauptstadt soll eben wenn man so will
die ostalgie siert werden die
palästinenser möglichst
hinauskomplimentiert werden und das
ganze zu einer enormen emotionalen
anspannung geführt weil die
palästinenser mit dem rücken zur wand
stehen sie wissen sie haben keine
unterstützung über diese
rechtsungleichheit ist er auch noch
gleich sprechen nur die hamas hat nach
dem das passiert ist weil sie gerade
geschildert haben ein ultimatum gestellt
und hat dann losgeschlagen das was sie
jetzt an sozusagen an israelischen
aktivitäten gegen die palästinenser
skizziert haben rechtfertigt dass das
eine terror-organisation innerhalb von
38 stunden 1050 raketen auf israel
abfeuert in der hoffnung dass einige die
israelische raketen ab werden passieren
und dort menschen töten das ist die auch
die frage ist rechtfertigt diese haltung
der hamas um das ist die
ausgangssituation des konflikts
diese dieses vorspiel
in israel das die hamas jetzt sozusagen
menschen mit raketen beschießt man kann
wie ich meine über palästinensische
gewalt nicht glaubwürdig reden ohne
gleichzeitig die israelische
staatsgewalt beim namen zu nennen das
eine bedingt das andere
man muss die hammers verhaft ich nicht
mögen aber wenn man sich vor augen führt
dass im gazastreifen bedingungen
herrschen wie wir sie uns hier nicht
vorstellen können der ist unbewohnbar
dieser streifen fast zwei millionen
menschen leben dort
es gibt das trinkwasser ist versalzen
die uhr vereinten nationen sagen man
kann dort eigentlich nicht mehr leben
trotzdem werden diese menschen dort
zusammengesetzt haben keine perspektive
die leute sind in einer sackgasse es
gibt keine politischen lösung und die
hamas reagiert darauf mit gewalt auch
mit terror und das muss man vorteil aber
das ist aber doch nicht die sozusagen
nachdem sie hat ja nicht das recht jetzt
mit terror zu reagieren weil sie glaubt
fühlt sich ungerecht behandelt und schon
die gegner auch in israel damit ja es
werden aber wenn man sich die geschichte
dieses konfliktes anguckt auch das
gehört zur wahrheit dazu sehr sehr viele
palästinensische opfer gegeben und wenn
man sie mal zusammen addieren wollte
über die letzten jahre hinweg dann
werden sie feststellen dass das tausende
von palästinensischen toten gegeben hat
das muss man ja an diesem konzert der
konflikte gehört allerdings auch dass er
in 1948 beim sechs tage gegen 167 und
bei mir und geburt krieg 19 73 arabische
staaten versucht haben israel nicht nur
anzugreifen sie haben angegriffen sie
waren der aggressor sondern auch wie sie
es damals genannt haben uns mehr zu
drängen also dass wir die vorgeschichte
des konflikts die sich bis zum heutigen
tag fortführt also wenn die
ursachenforschung betreiben müssen wir
die arabische aggression ja auch sehen
also bei einem respekt ist es immer
wichtig und richtig dass man die
aggression von allen seiten sehen aber
diese geschichtliche zusammenfassung die
sie gegeben haben
da muss man doch sagen da ließ sich
einiges mehr dazu zu sagen das ist ein
bisschen zu schlecht wie sie es
darstellen
aus unserer der westlichen sicht ist
israel grundsätzlich das opfer ein land
das in frieden leben wird und die
anderen versuchen es zu vernichten das
ist das hieße generativ war das nicht so
148 wenn sie aber sich die
palästinensische die arabische
perspektive ansehen dann werden die ganz
anders die empfindungen haben mit blick
auf die nackt war die vertreibung der
palästinenser im zuge der israelischen
staatsgründung mehr als die hälfte der
palästinensischen bevölkerung sind
damals vertrieben worden was im
allgemeinen bewusstsein überhaupt nicht
präsent ist das muss man auch erwähnen
sonst kommt man nicht zu einem gesammelt
ergebnis des krieges aber nicht als
ursache des krieges also wenn man mal
die geschichtlichen quellen sich
anschaut wenn man sich neulich bereits
die israelischen zeitungen schöner
beitrag zu lesen wie david ben gurion
zitiert wurde wie er damals
systematischem zu der israelischen
staatsgründung anempfohlen hat die
palästinenser zu vertreiben es ist also
nicht so gewesen dass die araber oder
die palästinenser grund gehabt hätten
die israelis nur zu begrüßen wir haben
aufgrund unserer eigenen geschichte eine
andere wahrnehmung dieses konflikt ist
das ist auch legitim aber wir müssen uns
auch einmal sagen wir mal die mühe
machen die perspektive der anderen seite
anzunehmen und es ist wichtig zu
begreifen
die gewalt ist jetzt eskaliert weil die
palästinenser mit dem rücken zur wand
stehen jahre lang hat die
palästinensische autonomiebehörde mit
der israelischen seite verhandelt sie
hat nichts bekommen von den israelis
rein gar nichts
und jetzt sind die radikalen da die
sagen gut das hat doch keinen sinn mit
den israelis zu hin wenn wir gewalt an
wir können das vorurteilen gewiss aber
das ist das ergebnis einer bestimmten
politik wenn wir ehrlich sind das was
hier gesagt wird zwei staaten lösung für
palästina die wird es nicht geben und
das ist er komme ich nochmal kaufen kann
dass das narrativ aber opfer gab es auf
beiden seiten
wir sind sozusagen die einen sind die
opfer herr zimmermann
es ist sehr angenehm hier stoppt ist am
rande einer innerdeutschen diskussionen
teilzunehmen
da sitzt ein deutscher und erklärt uns
wie die geschichte rief wie ein narrativ
wichtiger ist als das andere narrativ da
muss man sich sehr verständlich damit
auch befassen wie es dazu gekommen ist
dass überhaupt zwei aktive entstanden
sind und man musste etwas mehr über die
geschichte erzählen auch über die
vorgeschichte 48 um zu verstehen wie es
zu diesen zwei narrativen gekommen ist
und oben drauf das ist das wichtige
dieser hochnäsige haltung der europäer
wir wissen alles besser bescheid wir
sind westliche gewährten wir zeigen wir
euch palästinenser und israelis wie ihr
euch zu benehmen hat also das ist der
anfang des endes des beitrags des
positiven beitrags der westlichen
der vertreter der westlichen kultur
was bestimmt der deutschen in diesem
konflikt die lage ist differenziert zu
behandeln
es gibt sehr viele beschwerden der
palästinenser sie sehr gerecht werden
der zu rechtfertigen sind
damit sind auch linke leute aus israel
juden wie ich mit einverstanden
wir suchen nach einer lösung und nicht
nur um ein versucht die leute im nahen
osten zu belehren wie sie die geschichte
zu verstehen habe das wasser wieder sage
ich der tag war heute mehr oder weniger
die haltung und die vertretung der
haltung der hamas
ich interessiere mich auch zu erfahren
wie die leute die heute die autonome
gebiete beherrsche die piano zu diesem
konflikt stehen ob sie auch damit
einverstanden sind dass nur mit raketen
aus gaza auf israel eine lösung zu
finden ist klar dass da eine lange zeit
wo es keine verhandlungen zwischen
israel und den palästinensern gegeben
habt die aufgabe der westlichen mächte
die aufgabe der welt ist dann zu
intervenieren wo kein krieg ist bevor es
an dem krieg bevor ist einer
kriegerischen auseinandersetzung kommt
dann hat man zu integrieren und nicht
nur in dem moment wo es brenzlig
geworden ist und dann große ideen
entwickeln wie man eigentlich es hätte
besser tun können
vielleicht können wir ja darauf einigen
dass wir hier auch fragen stellen von
berlin aus sicherlich ist wollen wir
hier jetzt nicht als besonders schlau
dastehen aber sind auch fragen die man
stellen und fragen kann man zu allem
stellen frau das wasser zimmermann
gerade gesagt hat leider ja direkt zu
einem konflikt innerhalb der
palästinenser über nämlich die hamas ist
ja mit der organisation verfeindet die
sie hier in deutschland repräsentieren
die vertrag ist es ihnen denn gerade
weil ich vorhin gesagt haben wie wichtig
für die palästinenser der frieden ist
ist es ihnen denn recht das ihnen die
hamas mit diesen gewaltaktionen
eigentlich diese suppe versalzt
beziehungsweise ihnen in die suppe
spuckt
weil sie ja eigentlich an einem frieden
mit israel interessiert sind während die
hamas ständig mit gewalt versucht diesen
frieden zu unterlaufen wie stehen sie
zur hamas also eigentlich bin ich sehr
enttäuscht bis jetzt ich dachte wir
führen eine ausgeglichene debatte aber
sie kommen dann auch mit einer sehr
festen history ist geschichtlich
ausfälle oder doch nur eins gewünscht
und nicht eigentlich 48 was ja herr
lüders versucht sehr sehr sachlich
faktisch historisch zu erklären dass 48
für die palästinenser legris der
katastrophe vertreibung von ihrem
heimatland wo wir über 78 prozent kommt
vom weil es historischen palästina
verloren haben und trotzdem hat die plo
einen politischen kompromiss
historischen schmerzlichen kompromiss
akzeptiert einen palästinensischen staat
auf 22 prozent des historischen
palästina in westbank gaza und
ost-jerusalem akzeptiert und sich die
vier jahrzehnte engagiert was ist wo
sind wir heute wir sind heute in einem
von siedlungen zerschnitten usda von
einem isolierten jerusalem wo die ich
würde es nicht wiederholen
und diese systematische vertreibung und
verdrängung der palästinenser
stattfindet ist erlebe das physisch ich
gehöre zu der minderheit der
palästinenser die in ost-jerusalem
erlebt die in die situation im
abgeriegelten gaza und sogar in israel
die palästinenser werden diskriminiert
und das alles vor diskriminierendes
gremien diskriminierender
gerichtsbarkeit insofern ich weiß auf
beiden seiten gibt des friedens willige
israelis und palästinenser aber die
werden systematisch geschwächt wie
wurden systematisch geschwächt und was
im letzten monat diese zuspitzt
zuspitzung der völkerrechtswidrigen
maßnahmen in jerusalem
inter mandat jetzt heute am vorabend des
festes probieren eigentlich morgen den
fest feiern sollten wir trauern um stand
von vor eine stunde 67 lebens opfer tote
darunter 14 kinder und drei frauen
ein baby ein eine mutter sagte und ein
junges mädchen schreibt auch instagram
meine mutter besteht darauf dass wir
alle in einem zimmer schlafen damit
niemand um den anderen zaubert also sie
reden von von verhältnismäßigkeit aber
wo ist die verhältnismäßigkeit jetzt ich
weiß in 45 minuten können wir nicht
alles beleuchten aber man muss schon
sagen das ist das war keine
überheblichkeit von von herrn lüder das
so darzustellen dass den fakten und
heutzutage in den sozialen medien haben
alle das mitbekommen das gesicht der
besetzung der der soldaten der siedler
der orthodoxen der national
international ist ischen siedler in
jerusalem wie sie randaliert haben wie
sie frei maschinen durften aber auf der
anderen seite gläubige muslime dürften
nicht in die listen ein
wir haben die mehrheitlich die
jugendlichen in jerusalem haben und das
ist bewiesen haben mehrheitlich
friedlich aber das macht was sagen aber
es ist belegt das ist praktisch gab über
800 verletzte in jerusalem in chile
haben ihre augen verloren also es wurde
brutal gegen schließlich tanzt erkennen
wir haben diesen bilder hier gefällt
die haben kein internationales gehör
gehört auch gefunden
es wurde geschwiegen die situation heute
wir schweigen brechen ihr schweigen
darüber nicht im gegenteil wir
wir reden ja genau darüber dass was das
sein wird welche das schweigen der ja
ich glaube nicht dass es immer das
einseitig christina da kommt messi
kassiert wird euch bei der bei der von
den von der internationalen seite von
der kritik aber drehen den spieß mal um
was hat eigentlich israel an diesen
sachen oder welche schuld trägt ist weil
ihnen der israelische staat
es gab diese auseinandersetzungen es gab
auch radikale extremisten polnischer
seite die toten angerufen haben ebenso
wie die anderen toten den israelis es
gab einen massiven polizeieinsatz die
anderen sich wiederum die demonstranten
sich mit mit steinwürfen gewährt und es
gab michael das hat das ja gerade
angesprochen räumungsklagen gegen
menschen in ost jerusalem die dort in
häusern leben die vor 1948 offenbar
jüdischen siedlern gehört haben die
sollen jetzt auf diese häuser verlassen
da gibt es einen recht für israel ist es
auch umgekehrt für palästinenser nicht
denn die wurde 1948 ja auch vertrieben
bzw mussten flüchten und zwar noch in
viel größerer zahl ist diese rechtliche
ungleichheit in israel zwischen den
israelis und den palästinensern nicht
ein hauptproblem die eine dass eine
lösung dieses konflikts im wege steht
ja also am endeffekt gibt es diesen
riesen konflikt es gibt sehr viele
gründe
es gibt das diskriminierung ja aber wenn
wir jetzt ich denke dass wir in diesen
45 minuten nicht über den ganzen
konflikt von den letzten 80 jahre
renault wollen sondern ober was gerade
passiert und am endeffekt lörrach ist
eine geschichte aber dafür stadtteil in
dem diese räumung genau aber hamas hat
diese geschichte benutzt um zu sagen wir
sind die beschützer von jerusalem und
hamm raketen auf jerusalem geschossen
dann haben sie über 1000 raketen auf tel
aviv und andere städte in israel
geschossen
die hamas ist eine terrororganisation wo
eigentlich versucht auch politisch
ja ein gewinn zu bekommen ich denke
nicht dass kann man es wirklich die
bevölkerung von ihr ihre eigene
bevölkerung wirklich beachtet wenn hamas
auf tel aviv schießt weiß sie ganz genau
das ist eine reaktion von i frame kommt
man kann nicht 1000 raketen auf tel aviv
schicken und dann denken auch okay im
gaza passiert nicht grammer hat sich
bewusst entschieden dass zu eskalieren
und dass das ist jetzt auch opfer im
gazastreifen gibt das ist fürchterlich
und keiner will es aber hamas hat sich
dafür entschieden also das war ja nicht
israel man kann ja nicht denken dass
wenn über 1000 raketen auf eine stadt
geschossen werden dass treten das ist an
die stelle und es war wohl so dass hamas
ein ultimatum gestellt hat dass die
israelische polizei sich vom tempelberg
zurückzieht und die festgenommenen
freigelassen werden und danach kann dann
dieser angriff hat eine sache fällt ja
auf wir reden also von diesem
klassischen konflikt jetzt hammas gegen
gegen israel
andererseits hat israel zumindest in der
regierungszeit des vorhergehenden
präsidenten trump ja mit einigen also
unter dessen schirmherrschaft mit
arabischen staaten kontakt und
beziehungen aufgenommen
es gibt diplomatische beziehungen mit
den vereinigten arabischen emiraten mit
dem oman möglicherweise auch bald mit
saudi arabien also auf der einen seite
eine deeskalation mit das heißt sich
frieden zu schließen mit alten feinden
und auf der anderen seite diese wieder
verstärkte eskalation mit der hamas wie
geht das eigentlich zusammen wirken da
die arabischen staaten nebeneinander der
iran der ja die hamas als
terrororganisation unterstützt gegen
saudi arabien machen es sich da
gegenseitig das leben schwer warum sind
die arabischen staaten offenbar
gespalten in dieser frage also ich würde
noch einmal empfehlen wollen dass man
nicht nur für den einen topf wirft das
sind sehr verschiedene bereiche und
fragestellungen und natürlich sind open
starten die fliegende frieden
geschlossen haben mit israel sehr
unglücklich über diese entwicklung weil
die bevölkerung in den meisten
arabischen ländern ist emotional auf
seiten der partie
weil sie dort ein anderes empfinden
haben als hier wie er das in deutschland
haben hier in deutschland sehen israel
wie erwähnt grundsätzlich als unschuldig
verfolgt ist opfer das in frieden leben
will aber die palästinenser die araber
lassen die israelis nicht in frieden
leben es gibt aber auch eine andere
relativ hier in der deutschen
gesellschaft auch disco ja aber wenn sie
mal angucken was die politik sich
leistet und wenn die wie die mediale
berichterstattung erfolgt da muss man
sagen dass doch die sympathie und die
zuneigung für die israelische seite
überwiegt was ja auch völlig in ordnung
ist aber man sollte schon sollte ja hat
historische ursachen aber deswegen muss
man trotzdem nicht den blick für die
gegenwart verlieren der kern des
konfliktes gehen wir jetzt eskalieren
sehen und er wahrscheinlich weiter
eskalieren wird in den nächsten tagen
und wochen besteht darin wie erwähnt
dass wir eine seite in diesem konflikt
haben die israelische seite über alle
macht verfügt die andere seite ist eine
ohnmächtige seite warum gibt es diese
gewalten kann man natürlich philosophie
und über terror hier und terror da das
problem ist doch dass die palästinenser
über jahre hinweg versucht haben die
palästinensische autonomiebehörde mit
den israelis um frieden zu kommen wenn
wir ehrlich sind die israelische seite
so haupt nicht interessiert eine
zwei-staaten-lösung zuzulassen schauen
sie sich doch mal an die besiedlung des
servers ist eine systematische
strategische besiedlung da werden
straßen so gebaut dass die palästinenser
nicht mehr von a nach b kommen es wird
das westjordanland verschiedene teile
richtig segmentiert ost jerusalem wird
abgespalten von den palästinensischen
nachbarschaften
sie kommen als west mitbewohner nicht
noch aus jerusalem es sei denn sie haben
eine sondergenehmigung diese in der
regel nicht bekommen jahrelang haben die
palästinenser verhandelt sie haben
nichts bekommen von der israelischen
seite
wenn ich jetzt ein friedlicher
palästinenser wenn der überhaupt nichts
mit gewalt zu tun hat was passiert dann
meine stimme wird nicht gehört bin ich
ein palästinenser im exil in deutschland
beispielsweise ich will mich politisch
engagieren denn tue ich das als
palästinenser im kontext von bds bds
gilt aber hier als antisemitisch wenn
ich also als friedlicher palästinenser
keine möglichkeit habe meine stimme
verhör zu gehör zu verleihen
dennis natürlich gewalt eine option
unter den bedingungen unter denen die
menschen im gazastreifen leben ist es
nicht sehr realistisch anzunehmen dass
man dort eine art palästinensischer fdp
wählt sondern es geht natürlich in
richtung gewalt man kann sagen dass das
natürlich skrupellos ist dass die hamas
die opfer kalkuliert denn die wissen ja
dass die israelis zurückschießen werden
aber auf der anderen seite was haben sie
an die palästinenser zu verlieren aus
palästinensischer sicht ist mittlerweile
eine situation geschaffen
dass man im grunde genommen sich sagten
die haben nichts mehr zu verlieren wenn
wir nichts mehr zu verlieren haben dann
gehen wir doch aufs ganze
wenn wir die dinge analytisch betrachten
also leichtfertig dass gewalt daran das
rechtfertigt natürlich keine gewalt aber
die gewalt von denen sie dann auf der
wer ist denn der besatzer wäre es der
besetzte wer spielt dann welches land
ich nenne mal ein beispiel wir haben in
der deutschen politik in der westlichen
politik überhaupt keine differenzierende
wahrnehmung dieses konfliktes wir sind
sehr sagen wir mal sehr schnell dabei
eine deutschen politik zum beispiel
gegen russland sanktionen zu verhängen
weil es die krim annektiert hat
dieselben politiker die das gefordert
haben damals und dafür sind würden nie
auf die idee kommen dass denselben
maßstab den sie an russland anleger dies
waren anzulegen und zu sagen dann ist
geht aber so nicht was ihr tut denn ihr
habt dort nichts verloren das sind
internationale rechtsnormen die ganz
klar sagen es ist besetztes land israel
hat dort nichts verloren
unser famoser außenminister heiko maas
hat im letzten sommer als die
luxemburger regierung versuchte johnson
baum eine moderate resolution zu
verabschieden des inhaltes wir
verurteilen als eu die israelische
besatzungspolitik und er hat diese
besatzungspolitik verglichen mit der
annexion der krim
das hat aber maß verhindert dass eine
solche resolution durchkommt weil man
natürlich nicht hier israel unter druck
setzen wollte nur luxemburger zeitung
haben darüber berichtet deutsche
zeitungen nicht wir müssen ständig mit
zweierlei maß finden uns moralisch
überlegen aber wir haben eine situation
in palästina die dazu führt dass
allmählich die leute mit dem rücken zur
wand stehen und sie haben wenn ich
nichts mehr zu verlieren habe dann gehe
ich zur not auch wieder zu
selbstmordanschlägen über und nehmen
noch viele andere leute dass die frage
wird ja auch immer in einen anderen
maßstab gesehen also ich meine immer
wenn israel irgendwas tut schreibt die
welt wenn iran was macht wenn syrien was
macht in russland was macht also man
sagt immer man tut immer über die im
ober volker rechter reden wenn israel
und und und und und auch zu sagen ich
gebe ja auch die recht aber was aber was
ihr beide sagt ich denke hier nicht das
was meist also was den palästinensern
geschieht ist nicht richtig
aber wenn wir über maßnahmen reden dann
müssen wir auch ehrlich sagen dass man
israel
immer anders behandelt weltweit als
andere staaten aber auch zu dieser
schlussfolgerung wenn sie sich mal
angucken wie viele resolution ist in den
vereinten nationen gegeben hat die
israelische siedlungsaktivitäten
verurteilen nichts davon hat israel
jemals reagiert darauf trotzdem hat es
nie sanktionen gegeben beispielsweise
gegen israel ich meine weise sagen
israel wird ungerecht behandelt die
russen haben nach der annexion der kreml
sanktionen bekommt bis heute es wäre
völlig undenkbar dass die deutsche und
europäische die amerikanische politik
sanktionen verhängt gegen israel aus
genau dem selben grund mit dem man
damals am telefon aber häufig eine
diskussion die jetzt gegen ist ein
verhängt werden sollten bei der un die
hat sich israel nicht angehalten das
sind aber auch gegen arabische staaten
wie syrien hat von dieser option gegeben
gegen das habe ich nicht gesagt die es
gab solche resolution ist er hat sich
nicht daran gehalten aber arabischen
staaten hat sich auch nicht über
arabische staaten haben sich auch nicht
an die resolutionen der un gehalten der
punkt ist dass für eine situation haben
wo die palästinenser mit dem rücken zur
wand stehen und haben keine verbündeten
und sie haben in der westlichen politik
auch keine politiker und keine mehr oder
kaum weniger ich will das nicht um
zuletzt nachbargemeinden aber wenige
medienschaffende wenige politiker in
westlichen ländern die klare worte
finden an die adresse einer
völkerrechtswidrigen israelischen
politik lobby mehr zum abschluss auf den
israelischen philosophen am problem
hinzuweisen der klipp und klar
beschrieben hat was man als deutscher
sogar nicht formulieren könnte ohne
konsequenzen
dann konfrontiert zu werden damit ein
problem hat klipp und klar gesagt es
gibt im grunde zwei möglichkeiten
entweder wir finden zu einer
zwei-staaten-lösung zwischen israelis
und palästinensern
die ist nicht sehr wahrscheinlich wenn
das nicht passiert dann wird die lage
weiter weiter weiter eskalieren
und irgendwann kann es passieren dass
die israelische regierung sagt ok
beschlossen die palästinenser raus egal
wohin richtung jordanien libanon wohin
auch immer
aber es gibt jedenfalls dann eine
ethnische säuberung den kulissen hält
also mit ethnischer säuberung glaube ich
muss mal übrigens vorsicht hat als erste
frau tages ganz kurzen noch ein
zimmermann dann kommen sie wie sie nie
dran
herr zimmermann bitte wo wir gesagt ist
es angenehmer als statist und dieser
diskussion teilzunehmen
die frage die man sich stellen
nehmen muss ist eben wir daran
konstruktiv also die vorwürfe die man
von beiden seiten hört dazu das ist eine
art von partitionen gibt alle sind nicht
alle sind daher an dieser misere
schuldig und ist nirgendwo hin
auch wenn sie ihrem rivalen zitieren es
geht darum konstrukt viel zu denken ein
mal in der geschichte hat und
konstruktiv gedacht das war im jahr 93
alles zu einer vereinbarung kam zwischen
israel und den palästinensern
und da konnten wir sehen aha sowohl auf
palästinensischer seite als auch auf
israelischer seite gibt es statt gegen
die radikal in meiner perspektive als
historiker ist es klar man muss ja alles
unternehmen um die radikalen kräften zu
entkräften zu entkräften die irgendwie
aus dem konflikt auszuschalten dann
bleibt eben das was die große mitte ist
und da kann man irgendwie zu einem
kompromiss zu einer verständigung um es
ist klar für die israelische winkel wie
meine seite was den palästinensern viel
unrecht getan wurde lasse jetzt die
israelische politik von netanya oder
vorher von sharon eine politik ist die
schädlich war für den friedensprozess
aber wenn wir nur darauf beharren diese
fakten wieder und wieder zu erwähnen
hören wir zu nichts wir müssen jetzt
konstruktiv bearbeiten und das ist die
aufgabe der internationalen gemeinschaft
und die internationale gemeinschaft
kümmert sich um diese sache wenig
inklusive die arabischen staaten die
sind auch halbwegs 0 trat in dieser
situation und deswegen sind die
palästinenser alleine gelassen genauso
wie die israelische linke die alleine
gelassen sind man muss sich darum
bemühen bevor es so an der eskalation
kommt dass beide seiten ihre
verhandlungen fortsetzen
das wurde im jahr 2014 abgebrochen
seitdem haben wir keine verhandlungen
mehr zuständig für
freuen sich darüber sowohl die radikalen
auf der arabischen seite als auch die
radikalen
auf israelischer seite und so gehen wir
weiter in eine sackgasse
aus dieser sackgasse muss man nur aus
wohnen und das kann man nur mit einer
konstruktiven idee tun und das ist eben
eine aufgabe die international zu lösen
gut die konstruktive edv davis moshe
zimmermann spricht auch von einer
breiten mitte in bei den israelis und
den palästinensern die frieden wollen
die eine lösung wollen wie sähe denn
diese lösung aus dieser mitte die eben
diese gewalt und diesen diese krise
überwinden will
also zuerst muss man entscheiden
entweder will man frieden oder man man
man will kann steht dann und die
friedliche die die politische lösung die
bisher vorlag und konsens von der
internationalen gemeinschaft hatte ist
die zweistaatenlösung nun natürlich
nachtrunk der ja also eine art vollmacht
an die rechtsgerichtete regierung
netanjahus gesendet hat das jerusalem
anzuerkennen als als die hauptstadt
israels und die annexion der westbank
und die fortsetzende systematische
nochmal unterdrückung und ungleichheit
bis zum apartheid das hat ja der der
bericht der jungen watch organisation
menschenrechtsorganisation gezeigt ich
weiß dass türen sie nicht gerne und sie
wollen vielleicht nur auf ein auge sehen
was was da ist ich finde und ich
verstehe das nicht nur freunde
und wenn wir eine politische lösung
durchsetzt umsetzen wollen
wir haben nicht die luxus noch mehr
länger zu warten
die liegt auf dem tisch es ist fast zu
spät um das zu umzusetzen wären sie
nicht ja ich war sehr gut und die liegt
auf dem tisch sogar auch die 1
den start denn auch die normalisiert
haben die haben immer noch für die ein
bisschen ist ja so genannte
friedensinitiative auf dem tisch aber
bedingung ist erst die besatzung zu
beenden dass ein souveräner staat
palästina entsteht wo auf den besetzen
gebieten von 1900 setzen 760 mit ost
jerusalem als hauptstadt mit 1 jerusalem
offen für alle religionen alle gläubiger
alle kultur liebenden und so weiter und
so fort das ist die voraussetzung damit
wir diesen konflikt überwinden und das
findet immer noch eine mehrheit unter
den palästinensern leider unter der
israelischen gesellschaft darf ich
damals gab es gleich weiter für die die
weite die frage weiter und leiten an
frau jamin dass ich kurz nur das muss
auch zu warten ja bitte aber wir wissen
ja also das letzte wort ist wenn wir
diese politische lösung umsetzen wollen
dann müssen wir handeln es gibt
handlungsbedarf seitens der
internationalen gemeinschaft und wir
fordern nicht werden als rechtsnormen
instrumentarien ins werk selbst
umzusetzen das ist was wir fordern als
palästinenser als menschen die an
frieden immer noch glauben wollen und
wir arbeiten mit allen die daran glauben
auf israelischer seite dass dies
geschieht nun in solchen atmosphäre in
solchen eskalationen ist es auch
schwierig über eine konstruktive lösung
zu zu reden wenn die internationale
gemeinschaft nicht ernsthaft
einschreitet und wirklich gute und
dadurch sozusagen angekommen so bissig
noch aus
ja das nicht dass moderiert wird
politische und diplomatische arbeit
honoriert wird und menschenrechte für
alle gut das ist jetzt hier auch
angekommen
es ist jetzt mehrfach der begriff der
zwei staaten lösung auf gesehen das
heißt also dass israel und palästina
zwei souveräne staaten sind palästina
auf den vds hat gerade gesagt auf den
vor allem 167 von israel besetzten
gebieten allerdings nach einem krieg
dem israel angegriffen worden ist und
daran das kriegserlebnis ja auch wahr
dass die diese gebiete besetzt werden
ist relativ bisher nicht herausgerückt
ist diese zwei staaten lösung überhaupt
noch denkbar auch wegen der
siedlungspolitik israels oder muss das
irgendwann mein eine einstaatenlösung
münchen mit konfiguration und eine
möglichst friedlichen zusammenleben kein
mensch kann sich ja vorstellen dass
unter diesen bedingungen überhaupt noch
diese zwei staaten lösung möglich ist
sie haben sie jetzt eben selber
geantwortet also eine zwei staaten
lösung ist was was vielleicht sehr
erwünscht ist auf teile von beiden
seiten also auch wie professor
zimmermann gesagt hat auch von der
linken seite in israel europa mag immer
wieder von anfang an zu sagen ja wir
brauchen eine zwei staaten lösung am
endeffekt sehe ich persönlich nicht wie
das passieren konnte
auch wegen der siedlungspolitik aber
auch im endeffekt wer soll diesen staat
genau den palästinensischen staat
regieren hamas wo 1000 raketen auf tel
aviv schickt vater also also dir und
denkst wegen nicht weil ja die war zwar
abgesagt das passieren hofft vielleicht
auch ein grund wäre vielleicht auch ein
grund ist diese wahl
warum das jetzt warum es jetzt diese
eskalation passiert und am ende verlor
sie 1 1 statt wie in ein staat der
souverän ist und unabhängig wo sein volk
and würde und rechte hat der der
respektiert auch andere staaten war weil
er dann ende der in der
staatengemeinschaft eingegliedert ist
aber nicht ein besetztes volk das unter
besatzung liegt uns ständig system hat
das motorrad versand und dass er haye in
einem zwei- staaten-lösung der
tatsächlich erst dann ein land wirklich
souverän und auch wählen kann
zimmermann sie haben ja gerade die
position auch israels noch einmal gesagt
aber machen nicht auch die gegner von
benjamin netanjahus der viele fehler sie
können sich offensichtlich dieses ich
nenne es mal friedenslager in israel
also die die frieden wollen
machen sie es netanya und nicht auch zu
leicht sind sie untereinander nicht zu
sehr zerstritten haben sie auch kein
konzept das problem ist dass die
mehrheit in israel nationalistisch ist
nicht nur netanyahu und die gerechte
lösung die auf dem linken flügel gesucht
wir zusammen mit den palästinensern
nicht die populärste ist da haben wir
sehr viel zeit verloren
was ist das sehr große problem der
israelischen regierung deswegen muss man
sich überlegen die siedlungspolitik war
eine katastrophe ist an der katastrophe
das ist sehr verständlich ein
stolperstein auf dem weg zu einer zwei
staaten lösung
aber man muss etwas origineller über
zwei staaten denken
ich kann ja vorstellen zwei staaten
nebeneinander in jedem start eine
minderheit an die nationale minderheit
unter anderen seite was an eine lösung
sein
man kann auch weitergehen in richtung
föderation oder vielleicht konfiguration
da muss man etwas neues entwickeln
auf der grundlage des prinzips der zwei
staaten die die palästinenser haben
genau das recht wie israelis auf
nationale selbstbestimmung das heißt ob
am start was ist das ziel und von dort
aus muss man weiter gehen
gut die frage einen am ende am
entschuldung wir sind jetzt gleich am
ende der sendung
herr lüders droht ein krieg war ja die
frage im untertitel der sendung wird
dieser konflikt möglicherweise
glimpflich abgehen
tja man muss abwarten wie sich die
nächsten tage gestalten ich sehe im
augenblick nicht dass sich die lage
beruhigen könnte ich erlaube mir noch
einmal auf amrum zu verweisen der klipp
und klar gesagt hat wenn es einen
frieden geben soll in der region
unabhängig von der frage was die
palästinenser zu tun haben oder nicht
dann muss ich auch die israelische
gesellschaft fragen welche richtung sie
gehen will der hat darauf verwiesen dass
ein widerspruch ist auf der einen seite
ein jüdischer staat sein zu wollen
auf der anderen seite aber
ein demokratischer staat zu sein denn
wenn das kriterium demokratie an einer
ethnischen zugehörigkeit oder an einer
religiösen zugehörigkeit allein
konditioniert wird was ist dann mit dem
ganzen nicht juden und das leben
mittlerweile mehr nicht tun zwischen
mittelmeer und jordan flusses als juden
das muss man mal demografen zur kenntnis
nehmen frieden wird es nur geben wenn es
kompromisse gibt die rechtsgerichtete
israelische regierung wird keine
kompromisse eingehen mit den
palästinensern und der preis ist nicht
hartmanns teens davon völlig unerheblich
weil sie nicht zu sagen haben aber
ehrlich da muss man sicher treffen dann
in der mitte und sagen dann schließen
wir frieden also dass ich in einer
geschichte die palästinenser erleben der
schüler hat in israel im gange aber ja
gut dann muss man dieser ultra rechten
regierungen ist ja immer ganz klar die
leviten sehr gut sagen freunde wenn also
meister allerdings haben da an seiner
indischen wähler auch eine andere
regierung wählen ja aber im falle ja
aber ein schwimmer im falle russlands
hat man auch klare ansagen gewählt an
die regierung putin das kann man doch
mehr aber dann sehr wohl einen
unterschied zwischen russland und israel
was die humoristischen weiß ich ja ich
kann es jetzt an der stelle ganz bewusst
wirkliche abbrechen das war jetzt eine
sehr engagierte und ja ein einziger ist
entschuldigt ich muss nämlich findet es
darf nicht das letzte stärken stärken
gelten sondern die stärke des rechtes
und wir stehen nicht an der wand als
palästinenser wir haben immer noch
hoffnung
wir haben die jugendlichen die gezeigt
haben wie kreativ friedlich die auch
widerstand leisten und dass die
unterdrückung nicht weiter akzeptieren
wollen wie jedes andere volk in der welt
und ich denke dann wollen wir leben
dazu werde es zu diesen frieden auch
noch kommt soweit gut liess
entschuldigung moshe zimmermann antonia
jamin und michael lüders bleiben sie bei
uns
[Musik]